welcome to CBS this morning on this
Martin Luther King Day holiday it will
be a working holiday for President Trump
and members of Congress who are
preparing the case for removing him from
office this is a week that the president
faces charges in the Senate of abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress house
managers led by Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff are working again
today on the impeachment trials opening
presentation the president remains
defiant and has bolstered his legal team
we shang is covering the drama from the
White House Lygia what did the
president's attorneys say about how they
plan to defend him oh good morning
Anthony over the weekend in a six-page
formal response to the impeachment
summons the president's legal team
revealed their main arguments that the
entire process was tainted that the
articles fail on their face and on the
facts and that they were the result of a
quote brazen and unlawful attempt to
overturn the results of the 2016
election we could get an even closer
look at the president's impeachment
strategy by noon today when his team is
required to submit a legal brief to the
Senate the farmers are sticking with
Trump at the American Farm Bureau's
annual convention Sunday night president
Trump complained about getting impeached
we're achieving what no administration
has ever achieved before and what do I
get out of it tell me I get impeached
publicly the president was largely his
own defender in chief during the house
impeachment proceedings but mr. Trump
has a robust defense team for his Senate
trial including Ken Starr who led the
investigation that resulted in President
Bill Clinton's impeachment and Alan
Dershowitz a lawyer whose former clients
include OJ Simpson and convicted
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein since Friday
the constitutional expert has been on a
media blitz arguing the president did
not commit a crime these applications
are not impeachable then this trial
should result in an acquittal regardless
of whether the conduct is regarded as
okay by you or by me on Face the Nation
House Judiciary Chairman Jerry Nadler
called the claim nonsense any jury would
convict in three minutes flat that the
president betrayed his country by
breaking the law House impeachment
managers huddled throughout the weekend
on Capitol Hill and released a legal
brief outlining that President Trump
should be removed from office to
eliminate the threat that the president
poses to America's national security
Senate Democrats blamed Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell for leaving them in the
dark ahead of opening arguments on
Tuesday is so wrong that no one even
knows what his plan is a day and a half
before one of the most momentous
decisions any senator will ever make
Democrats continue pushing to have more
witnesses and evidence in the trial but
at least four Republicans have to vote
in favor to sources close to the
president's legal team say they are
preparing for the possibility with a
reminder that it's a two-way street and
they're ready to demand witnesses of
their own Tony we should thank you very
much